그래서 내부에 전혀 이제 스한 기운이
없게끔 이렇게 공사를 할 수가
[음악]
있었습니다네 안녕하세요 bsn 건축사
사무소 김준석 소장입니다 오늘은
저희가 신축 공사를 맞친 현장에 나와
있는데요 건물의 외관 디자인부터 내부
공간 구성까지 건물 전체를 한번
둘러보면서 관련된 내용들을
설명드리도록 하겠습니다 먼저 저희
필치는 제 3종 일반주거 지역으로
건폐율 50% 용적률 250% 제한을
받는 땅입니다 전면에 4m 도로에
접하고 있으며 측면에도 4m 도로에
접해 있는 모서리 필지입니다이 모서리
필지 같은 경우에는 도로의 너비
도로의 각도에 따라 가각 전제라는
것을 적용해야 되는데요 저희도 그
부분에 해당이 돼서 각각 도로 변으로
2mc 후퇴해 약 2m 면적이 제척게
됐습니다이 제척된 면적은 추 중공이
된 후에 건축물 대장에 기록될 때
제척된 면적이 제외되고 기록이 되게
되겠습니다 저희 땅이 접혀 있는 도로
너비가 4m 보니까 주차대수 확보를
위해서는 전면에 6m 도로 폭이
필요한데 부족한만큼 우리 땅에서 2m
후퇴해서 주차장 계획을 해 줬습니다
층 지상 5층 규모에 총 연면적 약
170평 정도 되는 규모로 신축이
되었고요 내부에는 엘리베이터 직통
계단 한 계소 연결돼 있으며 지하에는
여러 업종이 임대 가능하게끔 피난
계단 한 개소를 추가로 설치를
하였습니다이 피난 계단은 선큰 구조로
계획을 하여서 자연 체감과 환기가
가능하게끔 설계가 되어 있습니다 건물
외부 디자인은 주거 지역 내에
있는만큼 1조 사선 제한을 받는 사선
형태를 그대로 적용해서 디자인을 하게
되었는데요 주거 지역 내에 위치해
있다 보니 정복 1조 사선 제한을
받는데 1조 사선을 받는 것을 그대로
형태적으로 적용을 한 디자인이 가장
주된 포인트가 되겠습니다 4층부터
건물이 후퇴하면서 자연 발코니가
생기는데 4층 이상 되는 부분에는
사선형 의 매스를 적용해서 볼륨감을
나타내 주었고요 저층 부에서는 가장
큰 면적을 확보할 수 있는만큼 면적
확보를 위주로 디자인을 적용했습니다
그래서 저층부에는 형태적인 부분
대신에 상호를 포인트를 주어서 계획을
하였고요 도로변 쪽으로는 좀 넓은
창호를 계획을 하고 인접 대지 경계
쪽으로는 최소한의 창호를 계획을 해서
인접 건물들 하고의 간섭을 최소화하는
그런 디자인을 적용했습니다 후면부에는
화장실이 위치한만큼 최소한의 창호
크기만을 적용을 했는데 환기만
가능하게끔 그런 기능을 가지고 있는
창호들 반영이 되어 있습니다 주된
마감제는 스타코 마감으로 적용이 되어
있는데요 아무래도 다른 마감재들다는
건물의 볼륨을 더 잘 표현할 수 있는
마감제의 종류 중에 하나이다 보니까이
사선 형태를 적용한 볼륨감을 표현하기
위해서 마감제를 스타크로 선정을 하게
되었습니다 저층부 아고 고층부에 대한
마감제 색상을 달리 적용을 해
줌으로써 건물이 좀 분리되어 보이게끔
계획을 해 주었고요 각각 색상 당이
다른 구간에는 질감을 다르게 표현을
해서 그런 느낌들이 더 극대화될 수
있도록 마감제를 선정하였습니다 자
그럼 이제 내부로 한번 들어가 보도록
하겠습니다 지금 주출입구를 통해서
들어왔는데 바로 엘리베이터를 면하고
있고 그 옆쪽으로 계단이 위치해
있습니다 지금 저희 필치 같은
경우에는 이제 사각형 모양으로 되어
있는 땅이라서 이러한 코어 형태를
가지고 있는데요 저희가 보 드리는 또
다른 현장들 사례를 통해서
엘리베이터하 계단의 위치가 땅의
모양에따라 어떻게 달라지는지 하나씩
찾아보시는 것도 좋을 것 같습니다
밖에서 보셨던 것처럼 5층은 이렇게
사선 형태가 그대로 적용이 되어
있는데요이 사선 형태 구간에는 사선의
창을 적용해서 개방감 있게 좀 확보를
해 줬습니다 그리고 5층에 이제
숨겨진 비밀이 하나 있는데 저쪽을
보시면은 천창이 있어요 그래서 천창을
계획해서 최상층에서 이제 하늘을 볼
수 있도록 그런 포인트를 주었습니다
그리고 경사 창호에는 저희가 열리는
창을 따로 반영하지 않았는데 경사
창에 열리는 창 같은 경우에는 하자가
날 수 있는 확률이 높기 때문에 그런
위험 요소를 줄이고자 경사 창에는
열리는 창을 따로 적용하진 않았고요
나머지 창에 열리는 창과 발코니 쪽에
문을 통해서 자연 환기가 될 수
있도록 적용이 되어 있습니다 최상층의
공용실 같은 부분은 건물의 구조적인
형태가 그대로 노출될 수 있도록
별도의 천장 마감을 하지 않았는데요
이렇게 자연스럽게 건물의 구조적인
모습이 보여질 수 있도록 적용을
했습니다네 이제 4층으로 내려왔는데요
4층은 3층 다 면적이 작아지게
됩니다 그래서 3층의 지붕을 자연
발코니로 사용할 수 있게 되는 장점을
갖고 있습니다 그래서 가장 큰
발코니를 갖고 있는 공간이 4층인데
한 10평 정도 되는 공간 서비스로
받을 수 있는 면접이라고 보시면
됩니다 그리고 지상층의 경우 각
층마다 3M 층고를 가지고 있어요
그래서 높이가 3m 실제 이제
내부에서 봤을 때는 천장 고라고 하는
천장까지의 높이는 약 2.8m 정도가
확보가 됩니다 20cm 없어지게
되는데 그중에 15cm
층하배관
사전 마감 몰탈이 하는 마감 두께가
약 5cm 정도 돼서 20cm 정도의
높이가 줄어들게 됩니다네
성이 되어 있는데요 지금 보이는요
전면 도로변 쪽으로 연속되는 커트너
계획을 해서 좀 개방감을 확보를 해
줬습니다 그리고 건물의 형태적인
부분을 따라서 사선 형태로 된 창
창문도 계획이 되어 있고 벽도 또 그
형태를 따라서 사선 형태로 적용이 된
부분입니다 우리 건물에 있어서 좀
전면 도로변 쪽으로 가장 부각되는
포인트라고 볼 수 있는데요 인접대지
쪽에 마주하고 있는 건물들과의 시선
간섭을 좀 피하기 위해 도로 변
쪽으로 좀 개방감을 확보해 주었던
그런 사례였습니다 그리고 내부에
있는이 기둥 두 개소가 사실 설계를
하면서 가장 좀 아쉬웠던 부분인데
지상 1층에 위치된 주차장 때문에
어쩔 수 없이 호텔에서 기둥이 이제
형성이 됐어야 되는 그런 구조였고
저희가 설계적인 기법으로이 기둥을
없앨 수 있었지만 그렇게 되면 이제
특수 구조 건축물이 되기 때문에
별도의 구조 심이 진행이 필요했습니다
구조 심이 진행하게 되면은 설계 기간
뿐만이 아니라 공사 비용도 같이
상승을 할 수 있기에 좀 어쩔 수
없이 기둥을 존치 하는 방법으로
유지를 했습니다 그리고 이제 복도
쪽으로 창문을 두 개소를 계획을 해
줬어요 왜냐면 엘리베이터를 타고
내렸을 때 또는 계단에서 올라왔을 때
벽을 마주하고 있으면 좀 답답해 보일
수 있기 때문에 안쪽으로 열려 있는
모습을 보여줄 수 있도록 복도 쪽으로
창문을 계획을 해 줬습니다 물론
내부에는 사용자가 불편하다고 하면은
안쪽에서 블라인드를 치거나 가려서
사용할 수 있게끔 적용이 돼 있습니다
계단실 중간에 내려와 있는데요 지금
보이는이 공 공간이 사실은 서비스
공간입니다 설비 배관들이 이동하는
설비 공간 통로로 계획을 했었는데
공사를 하면서 그 배관들을 다른
곳으로 위치를 이동시킬 수 있어서
남는 공간이 됐어요 그래서이 공간을
창고로 활용하면 좋겠다라고 저희
중개법인 팀의 상무님께서 말씀해
주셔서 문을 설치해서 이렇게 창고
공간으로 활용을 하게 됐습니다 면적이
약 한 평 정도 나오는 공간이고요
건물에서 사용하시기에는 굉장히 좋은
공간 공간이 될 거 같습니다네 지금
지하 1층에 내려와 있는데요 지하는
약 50평 정도 되는 공간이고요 지금
층고는 5.2m 적용이 되어 있습니다
친구는 5.2m 이만 실제 이제 내부
천장 높이는 한 4.7m 4.5m
정도 확보가 되는 그런 공간이라고
보시면 됩니다 앞서 말씀드렸던 것처럼
층의 경우에는 이제 추후에 다양한
임대 업종을 임차하기 위해서 간이
스프링 쿨러가 다 설치가 돼 있고
외부로 나갈 수 있는 별도의 피한게
단이 성큰 공간하 함께 구성이 되어
있습니다 지금 지하에 내려와 있는데
많이 습하지 않거든요 그동안 이제
비가 여러 차례 좀 오고 했었는데
누수가 된 흔적도 안 보이고 공간이
습하지 않은게 바닥이랑 벽 쪽에 이제
방수 처리를 다 해 줘서 그렇습니다
바닥에는 배수판 벽체는 이중벽이라
그래서 방습벽 고호를 해 줬고요
그래서 내부에 전혀 이제 습판 기운이
없게끔 이렇게 공사를 할 수가
있었습니다 외부에 있는이 성큰 공간을
통해서 일부 채강이 가능하고 또
창문을 개했다 환기가 가능하게끔 지하
구조를 갖춰 놨는데요 이렇게 이제
여러 가지 설계 기법을 적용함으로써
지하 공간을 더욱 쾌적한 컨디션
환경으로 만들어 줄 수 있었습니다네
그리고 1층의 경우는 지금 주출입구에
들어가서 1층 내부 공간으로
들어가게끔 출입구 계획이 되어
있는데요 추후의 임차인의 목적에
따라서이 외부 출입구에서 바로
연결해서 출입 동선을 만들어 줄 수
있도록 일단은 창으로 먼저 계획을 해
놨습니다 나중에는이 부분을 이제
문으로 교체를 해서 접근할 수 있는
동선을 확보해 주면은 좋을 것
같습니다네 여기까지 최근에 신축된
현장을 둘러봤는데요이 내용이 여러분께
도움이 되었다면 구독과 좋아요
부탁드리겠습니다 그럼 다음 시간에 또
찾아뵙겠습니다
[음악]
감사합니다 l